ravi de vous retrouver sur public sénat
la semaine dernière d'assiette ciolos
commissaire européen à l'agriculture
étaient reçus au sénat
il a été auditionné par les sénateurs
audition que je vous propose de revoir
cet après midi et au cours de laquelle
il a annoncé des mesures de soutien au
secteur laitier
d'ici l'automne le commissaire européen
qui a donc précisé qu'il n'attendrait
pas la réforme de la pac pour annoncer
de telles mesures
bon après midi à tous bien monsieur le
commissaire monsieur le président mes
chers collègues je le commissaire
permettez moi avant de céder la parole
dans un instant à mon collègue jean paul
emorine président de la commission des
affaires économiques du développement
durable et de l'aménagement du
territoire de vous souhaiter en mon nom
personnel mais surtout au nom de la
commission des affaires européennes du
sénat
la bienvenue au palais du luxembourg
vous y est particulièrement attendu car
l'agriculture est en crise toutes les
filières sont en difficulté les
agriculteurs doute de leur avenir non
plus de perspectives et pour certains
d'entre eux envisagent tout simplement
de quitter leur exploitation pourtant
l'agriculture est au coeur de toutes les
modernités de ce 21e siècle
à condition que l'on veuille bien
regarder la réalité en face c'est à dire
revenir à l'acte premier d'agriculteurs
produire des biens de consommation
disposer des méthodes et structures
assurant la compétitivité de ses
exploitations assurer un partage
équitable de la valeur ajoutée tout au
long des filières et conforter nos
entreprises agroalimentaires qui sont
autant d'entités assurant richesse et
aménagement du territoire
si l'europe doit être ouverte sur le
monde
elle ne doit pas pour autant être
offerte convient de repenser à mon avis
l'attitude de l'europe dans cet
environnement très concurrentiel
convient de continuer de disposer
d'outils de régulation réactif qui sont
au coeur de la philosophie de la pâques
une pâques que l'on doit repenser dès
maintenant pour qu'en 2013 nous
puissions assurer sa pérennité
votre tâche est immense nous comptons
sur vous et nous avons confiance en vous
pour refonder cette pac une politique
qui dans les années 60 a été tellement a
été l'élément fédérateur de l'europe est
une politique qui demain sera
indispensable à la survie de nos
territoires
merci à jean bizet de me donner la
parole je voulais dire à monsieur le
commissaire combien nous avions plaisir
à l'accueillir au sénat de la république
française et nous avons eu un entretien
avec le président larcher qui était un
peu court mais qui était qui a préparé
les prémices de cette audition dire à
monsieur le commissaire qu'il arrive à
un moment charnière puisque nous avons
une bilan de santé de la politique
agricole commune que nous a présenté
quelqu'un qui connaît très bien michel
barnier qu'aujourd'hui notre
gouvernement nous propose une loi de
modernisation agricole où nous allons
essayer d'adapter notre agriculture au
contexte de l'union européenne et nous
apparaissait bien naturel que le
commissaire en charge de l'agriculture
et du développement rural viennent
donner sa vision peut-être à court terme
mais peut-être à plus long terme sur
cette politique agricole commune
rappelait j'ai le commissaire si vous le
permettez que vous êtes diplômé des
écoles françaises puisque vous êtes
docteur en sciences agricoles de
l'université de montpellier en 2006 donc
les gens du sud sont très heureux de
vous avoir comme diplômés et vous êtes
diplômé d'économie et du développement
agricole à l'école nationale supérieure
agronomique de roenne mes chers
collègues
voyez vous êtes les prix le sud le nord
et ouest de notre beau pays et pour le
bourguignon que je suis je vous sens un
diplômé de notre grand pays
donc cette commissaire nous allons vous
céder la parole tout de suite pour que
vous puissiez présenter cette
perspective agricole de l'union
européenne
je crois qu'après nous pourrons ouvrir
bien sûr aux questions de nos collègues
merci de recommencer merci monsieur le
président
distingués membres de membres de ce nom
la france mais que c'est pour cette
invitation
oui j'ai tout dit en france et j'ai
essayé d'extraire de toute cette
expérience
tout ce que j'ai pu sur la compréhension
de l'europe aussi puisque je sais que la
france est très attachée à l'europe
l'agriculture française a pu se
développer et évoluer dans le cadre de
l'euro de la politique agricole commune
j'espère que dans l'avenir la france
soutiendra les projets européenne au
mois dé manière tout aussi intense
qu'elle l'a fait jusqu'à présent
je suis très heureux d'être devant vous
aujourd'hui je souhaitais le faire comme
je lai déjà fait devant le bundestag en
allemagne comme je le ferai dans
d'autres états membres puisque avec
l'adoption du traité de lisbonne le
passage à la codécision pour la
politique agricole commune
vous aussi vous aurez un rôle important
dans ce processus de décision de réforme
de la politique agricole commune donc en
tant que commissaire européenne à
l'agriculture et au développement rural
est en charge de proposer d'avoir
l'initiative sur l'adaptation de cette
politique agricole commune ça
m'intéresse d'avoir ces échanges de vue
avec avec vous tout en espérant que vous
allez avoir et j'en suis convaincue de
sa une contribution très constructive à
ce processus de réforme de la pac
on en discute beaucoup de l'agriculture
ces derniers mois puisque même si toute
l'économie le secteur social économique
européenne plusieurs secteurs
économiques d'ailleurs on subit les
effets négatifs de la crise que l'europe
non seulement l'europe le monde a connu
ces derniers temps c'est vrai quand il
s'agit de l'alimentation quand il s'agit
de nos territoires
peut-être qu'on les voit plus que s'il
s'agit de deux prix de notre voiture
audet nos vêtements ou d'autres biens
qui sont qui sont affectés mais je pense
qu'il faut situer
cette situation difficile du secteur
agricole
actuellement dans ce contexte général
l'agriculture comme d'autres secteurs
n'ont pas été épargnés mais ça justifie
je pense une fois de plus l'existence
d'une politique agricole et une
politique agricole commune iter donc
pour le court terme puisque ça a été
discuté ces derniers jours
aussi en france je peux vous assurer
c'est que j'ai dit il ya quelques jours
danemark c'est que je le dis aussi
depuis bruxelles on a un certain nombre
de mécanismes à disposition la
commission n'hésitera pas d'utiliser ces
mécanismes quand la situation va le
demander on va essayer de faire en sorte
que ce mécanisme qu'on a à disposition
une intervention sur les marchés dans
des situations de crise sont utilisées
des manières les plus efficaces mais
vous le savez que cette intervention ses
interventions sur les marchés sera
marchés ouverts joue un rôle de plus en
plus de filets de sécurité
donc il faut qu'on puisse s'assurer que
ses interventions sur les marchés en
tant que filet de sécurité en dernière
instance donne vraiment des bons
résultats mais justement puisqu'on à ces
gens des situations il faut qu'on pense
aussi à la perspective de la politique
agricole commune et vous savez qui il
nous faut toujours un certain temps de
trois années pour préparer une réforme
de l'envergure 1 et celle qu'on est en
train de préparer maintenant je vous
rappelle que la dernière réforme
profonde de la bac a été décidée en 2003
et que la réflexion avait commencé dans
les années 2000 donc on est maintenant
dans la situation où on a l'occasion de
repenser notre politique agricole
commune dont la perspective de 2020
peut-être même après 2020 dans ce
processus de réflexion préparatoire à
cette réforme
je pense qu'il faut prendre en compte la
situation dans laquelle on se trouve
actuellement dans l'union européenne
notamment en ce qui concerne
l'agriculture camp nou contre le fait
que ces dernières années l'union
européenne a connu un élargissement
importante qui a renforcé sa capacité de
production agricole mais il ya beaucoup
renforcé aussi la diversité des
agricultures
d'ailleurs des prises en plus on ne peut
plus parler d'une agriculture européenne
mais des agricultures européennes au
plus tôt des territoires agricoles
européenne et donc il faut qu'on soit
conscient de ça pour qu'on puisse
trouver les bons moyens pour mettre en
valeur ces territoires agricoles
européennes et ses potentiels agricoles
mais faire cette mise en valeur tout en
tenant compte aussi de des attentes de
la société européenne qui au delà de la
sécurité alimentaire qui reste un
élément clé de la politique agricole
commune et qui est d'ailleurs renforcée
encore par le traité de lisbonne
récemment adopté mais au delà de la
sécurité de la pression des marchés
les contribuables européens les citoyens
européens est de plus en plus intéressés
par les résultats que l'agriculture
donne concernant l'environnement
concernant le bien-être des animaux
concernant le maintien de l'agriculture
sur l'ensemble des territoires européens
concernant les liens entre l'activité
agricole et l'activité économique autres
que celles agricoles en milieu rural
pour que justement on puisse maintenir
des campagnes vivantes en espace rural
dynamique
donc c'est toucher tous ces défis qu'on
doit prendre en compte dans la réforme
qu'on est en train de préparer de
réfléchir sans oublier les
préoccupations et même les effets convoi
économiques sociaux environnementaux des
questions liées au changement climatique
le changement climatique auquel on doit
donner des réponses l'agriculture peut
et doit donner des réponses
ah ça non seulement dans le sens de
contribuer à la réduction d'émissions de
gaz à effet de serre l'agriculture l'a
déjà fait et c'est le seul secteur de
l'économie européenne qui atteint déjà
une réduction de 20% d'émissions de gaz
à effet de serre de gamme d'épi 97
depuis 90 ans jusqu'en 2007 alors que la
moyenne européenne pour les autres
secteurs cédé 8% donc l'agriculture a
déjà fait l a prouvé qu'elle peut faire
des choses dans ce sens elle pourra
aussi faire plus dans l'avenir il faut
qu'on lui donne les moyens et il faut
que ces contributions ses attentes de la
société on le prendre en compte au sein
de la politique agricole commune
je vous rappelle aussi le projet que la
commission européenne a proposé à
l'europe l'europe l'horizon 2020
pourrait relancer la croissance en
europe une croissance qui doit être plus
intelligente durable et plus inclusive
assez objective aussi l'agriculture
pourrait y contribuer et la pac réformée
va prouver que l'on peut prendre en
compte une agriculture un espace rural
qui préserve l'emploi et qui stimule la
création l'emploi donc une croissance
inclusive que l'agriculture contribue à
une gestion durable des ressources
naturelles puisqu'elle travaille avec la
matière vivante l'agriculture très
souvent et que l'agriculture sera aussi
par la stimulation des processus
d'innovation contribué à adapter cette
technologie pour qu'elles soient plus
compétitives pour qu'elles soient plus
respectueux de l'environnement pour
qu'on produise des aliments plus sains
et plus sûr en utilisant les résultats
de la recherche scientifique
donc toutes ces questions sont nos
préoccupations pour la pac de l'avenir
on va essayer de trouver les réponses
ensemble pour conclure je vais juste
vous dire en termes de calendrier que je
viens de lancer un débat public pour que
c'est cette discussion autour de
l'avenir de la pac ne restent pas limité
dans le cercle restreint des experts en
agriculture ou des agriculteurs puisque
la pac s'adresse à toute la société
européenne et il faut que ça soit très
clair
mise en vue en valeur cet aspect donc
j'ai lancé ce débat public pour voir les
contributions les attentes les réactions
des citoyens européens à travers des
différents formes d'organisation et
d'expression publique et citoyenne au
mois de juillet à me jouer je vais
organiser une conférence à bruxelles
pour en tirer les conclusions de ce
débat public au mois de novembre
ensuite j'envisage de proposer une
communication de la commission qui va
donner les grandes lignes les grandes
orientations de la réforme de la pac que
je propose au conseil et au parlement
pour ensuite sur la base des discussions
des consultations autour de cette
communication de la commission en 2011
20 mi 2011 au mois de juin 2011 de venir
avec les paquets législatives de réforme
de la pac en espérant qu'on arrivera à
finaliser le processus décisionnel d'ici
fin 2012 pour que après 2013 on puisse
mettre en oeuvre cette réforme
merci beaucoup de m'avoir écouté je suis
prêt à répondre à vos questions
merci monsieur le commissaire on va donc
d'emblée donné la parole à un certain
nombre de collègues qui ont des tas de
questions à vous poser peut-être que on
pourra me demander un deux premiers à
gérard césar qui donc que le rapporteur
de la loi et les mâts d'une part et
madame bourget qui est co présidente du
groupe de travail sur la pac au niveau
de la commission affaires européennes
dans un premier temps ces deux personnes
oui merci ce président si le commissaire
vous avez expliqué votre désir justement
par rapport à l'union européenne et par
rapport à la polluent à la pac après
c'est important de le dire j'aurai deux
questions très précises et très courte
pour laisser la place à des collègues
ça concerne le problème de l'assurance
que nous voulons mettre en place en
france au titre de leurs éléments
concernant justement les aléas
climatiques
la question que je peut opposer
nous savons que nous avons aujourd'hui
des marges de manoeuvre au niveau
national par rapport dans kobylin de
santé de la pac
la question que je voulais opposé quelle
faculté pour attendre dans la nouvelle
pac de continuer à soutenir les
dispositifs d'assurance ça c'est un
point très important et nous sommes en
train aux niveaux avec le prisa et
maureen de parler justement de la
réassurance privé mais aussi public
c'est un point qui fondamental pour nous
car si on fait une loi de modulation de
l'agriculture en france et qu'on ne voit
pas on ne peut pas prévoir un dispositif
d'assurance c'est pas une bonne loi
c'est notre point de vue deuxième point
qui concerne la viticulture c'est le
problème des droits de plantation
la présidente la chancelière allemande
s'est prononcée ainsi que le mr et
culture pour le maître maintenir donc
que jusqu'en 2018
les droits de plantation est-ce que
quelle est votre position par rapport à
la viticulture de qualité et aux ou
maintienne ses droits de plantation
voilà deux questions très rapide
monsieur commissaire merci merci gérard
bernadette bourzai en précisant si vous
voulez que le commissaire doit
impérativement nous quitter vers 11h15
donc si chacun peut poser simplement une
question et jean paul emorine et moi
même on collectera l'ensemble des
questions qui vous préoccupent
et on les fera passer elles seront
traitées voilà comment on peut procéder
bernadette bourse merci merci monsieur
le commissaire de l'exposé rapide mais
très clair que vous nous avez fait et
qui m'évitera de poser une question sur
les caractéristiques de la future pac en
matière d'alimentation d'attentes des
citoyens et de changement climatique
vous les avez déjà évoqué je voulais par
contre souligné qu' une des critiques
qui est fait à la politique agricole
commune celle inégalités de répartition
des aides et j'ai pris connaissance du
rapport ou du projet de rapport de
monsieur laguiole au parlement européen
qui souligne que l'écart était de un à
trois entre la moyenne des aides
attribuées dans les pays de l'europe de
l'est et ceux de l'ancien pays des
anciens pays membres également certains
secteurs ont été considérablement aidé
d'autres l'ont beaucoup moins été voire
pas du tout la question est comment
pensez vous réduire les inégalités et à
revenir dans la prochaine pac à une
répartition plus équitable des aides de
façon effectivement à faire en sorte que
l'ensemble de l'europe soit reste une
zone de production agricole ma deuxième
question portera sur l'environnement
les agriculteurs français considèrent
parfois que les conditions
environnementales qui leur sont imposées
ne sont pas respectés de la même façon
dans tous les pays européens il parle
également d'inégalités sur le plan
social et un pays n'a pas les moyens de
vérifier ou non la véracité de ces
questions est ce que la commission
européenne est en mesure de mener une
étude qui garantirait qu'effectivement
les conditions environnementales et
sociales sont respectés de la même façon
dans tous les pays
et enfin je voulais souligner parce que
c'est une préoccupation de l'élu de
montagne que je suis que le découplage
total des aides de la production
constitue un grand risque de mon point
de vue notamment dans les zones
montagneuses ou un handicap et en
particulier dans les zones d'élevage
donc je souhaite savoir si vous
envisagez de maintenir un certain
couplage dans ces territoires en
difficulté merci bien merci ma chère
collègue vous êtes très nombreux ou leur
poser des questions odette herviaux et
jacques blanc pour une première série
mercy mais cette maison monsieur le
commissaire merci beaucoup de votre
intervention c'est vrai que
partiellement nous avons apprécié
l'esprit d'ouverture et de débats qui
vous anime je crois que c'est assez
nouveau et c'est très intéressant pour
nous sur ce sujet gérer deux questions
là aussi vous avez dit vous même que les
préparations aux changements prennent un
certain temps et pour revenir à ce qui a
été appliqué ont commencé à appliquer en
2003 les décisions ont été mises en
place entre 2000 2003 et on s'est aperçu
depuis longtemps que cette décision face
aux crises face aux nouveautés du monde
tel qu'il est actuellement sont souvent
obsolètes et donc je trouve très
intéressant que nous puissions revenir
complètement là dessus au moins ouvrir
le débat et
faire des nouvelles propositions parmi
ces propositions où ces questions
une première question vous avez parlé
des outils de régulation
certains sont eux aussi dépassé mais il
y en aura des nouveaux peut-être il me
semble que ces outils sont souvent
utilisés uniquement en période de crise
donc à votre avis n'est-il pas
nécessaire d'avoir de penser une
régulation publique beaucoup plus
continu que d'actionner à certains
moments des outils qui n'ont pas
toujours fait leurs preuves
et puis le deuxième point c'est sur les
secteurs en crise notamment le lait
actuellement certains de mes collègues
ont rappelé que nous étions en période
de préparation d'une nouvelle loi sur
des mécanismes qui assouplirait les
règles de la concurrence
que peut-on mettre en place d' assez
contraignant de manière à éviter quand
même un souci un peu particulier et que
pensez-vous sur une sorte de deux prix
plancher de manière à accompagner cette
c contractualisation et puis dernière
petite question
vous êtes issu d'un pays très très
agricole aussi où l'agriculture les
agricultures sont très diverses
globalement jusqu'à présent on a eu
l'impression que l'avenir des petites
structures n'étaient pas forcément le le
souci de l'europe
comment pensez vous aider ces petites
exploitations où ces moyennes
exploitations à a perduré pour maintenir
cette diversité de l'agriculture
notamment dans les territoires où
l'agriculture a fait le choix des hommes
au bénéfice du territoire plutôt que les
choix des grandes structures
merci merci jacques blanc une dernière
question pour une première phase oui
d'abord monsieur le commissaire
permettez moi de vous dire que vous êtes
un espoir pour nos jeux vous entendu au
comité des régions d'europe
tous ceux qui sont préoccupés par
l'avenir des zones en difficulté en
particulier de la montagne ont apprécié
ce que
vous avez présenté comme objectif alors
je me permets que vous demandez
brièvement mais quel est à vos yeux
l'avenir de cette politique d'abord de
développement durable entre et avec les
rapports entre premier et deuxième
pilier avec les les positions
différentes des différents états
certains vous d'en faire passer tous du
premier pays au deuxième pilier
si la politique agricole de montagne
peut espérer être confortée dans sa
double dimension une dimension de
production et il ya le problème de la
reconnaissance même de la signature des
produits de montagne et bien sûr aussi
une fonction environnementale mais on ne
voudrait pas qu'on ferme les yeux sur
l'exigence de la fonction économique de
la production agricole
enfin pour être bref dernier point c'est
je revienne un peu à la politique de
développement rural et surtout à la
cohésion territoriale la cohésion
territoriale est devenu un objectif dans
le traité de lisbonne de la politique
européenne
cannes est il par rapport aux problèmes
spécifiques qui y aura-t-il une approche
spécifique de la montagne pour assurer
la cohésion territoriale
merci mon cher collègue monsieur comme
sien vous avez la parole je vais essayer
d'être très bref pour ne pas prendre
beaucoup de temps mais vous comprenez
bien que ce sont 2 ce sont des questions
qui demande aussi beaucoup d'éléments de
réponse mais j'espère pouvoir montrer
des éléments de réponse à travers les
propositions qu'on va faire
prochainement prochainement mais
concernant la les aléas climatiques et
le système assurantiel c'est une
question qui a déjà été discutée le
bilan de santé de la pac
j'envisage d'approfondir ces sujets et
de venir avec des propositions dans la
pac 2013 puisque
cette approche de marché disant elle
pourra se faire à travers des
instruments types de filets de sécurité
qui intervient dans les situations de
crise à travers des fonds assurantiel
qui permettront aussi de contribuer à
une stabilité des revenus des
agriculteurs contient des fortes
variations de prix puisque donc je pense
qu'il faut qu'on puisse agir d'un côté
pour éviter aux pour pouvoir répondre
dans des situations de crise donc avec
mécanistiques filet de sécurité
il faudra qu'on puisse répondre aussi à
la question de la volatilité des prix
qui apparaît qu'on présente de plus en
plus nos matches et donc il faut
s'adresser à ça avec des mécaniques
spécifiques
et puis il faut aussi qu'on propose des
instruments à travers lequel on renforce
la capacité de négociation des
agriculteurs concernant les prix puisque
je pense que dans un marché de plus en
plus ouvert une maîtrise des quantités
une maîtrise des prix administrés ne
sont pas vraiment efficace si en plus ce
type de mécanisme de gestion sont liées
à des budgets à des contributions
budgétaires
vous comprenez très bien puisque vous
décidez aussi sur l'utilisation de
l'argent public c'est de moins en moins
acceptable de ne pas avoir un contrôle
budgétaire d'une année sur l'autre sur
les dépenses sur certains politiques
donc c'est pour ça qu'ils il faut qu'on
trouve des instruments qui nous permet à
répondre à ces différents situation avec
une intervention de l'état mais qui
qu'ils soient là non pas pour tout
maîtriser mais pour intervenir pour
corriger des défaillances qui peuvent
apparaître les marchés donc je pense
qu'avec ça j'ai répondu aussi à d'autres
questions concernant les futures
propositions pour les droits de
plantation où la viticulture
je donnerai la même réponse très
rapidement que pour le secteur laitier
quel peut être l'effet d'un contrôle de
la de la production ce marché qui est de
plus en plus ouvert on savait pas dire
que le droit de plantation ne peuvent
pas jouer un certain rôle peut-être pour
certains types de vins et dans certains
types de régions spécifiques mais je
vais juste vous rappeler que cette
décision a été prise par les états
membres lors du bilan de santé de la pac
deux éliminations de de ce mécanisme des
droits de plantation
mais si je me souviens un bond dont la
même décision est prévu que les états
membres subsidiairement peuvent décider
dans cette situation de prolonger dans
certains régions de prolonger ce système
des droits de plantation
mais bien sûr je vais pas me borner à
des manières d'y entrer inflexible à des
décisions qui ont été prises si dans
l'avenir
cet instrument adapté pour à démontrer
qu'ils puissent toujours juin place
peut-être comme un rôle combiné peut
être avec d'autres mécanismes je serai
ouvert a analysé ça mais pour l'instant
c'est une décision qui a été prise il
faut s'y tenir cette décision du conseil
encore des états membres dont la
répartition des inégalités des aides
oui on va là on va l'aborder en abordant
les paiements directs de notre angle sur
la base des nouvelles critères du nouvel
objectif des nouvelles des critères de
distribution des critères qu'on va
appliquer de manière uniforme à tous les
états membres bien sûr ce n'est pas
d'hier que le niveau de paiement sera
uniforme à tous les régions à tous les
types d'agricultures puisqu'il ya
certaines différences mais il faut voir
comment faire pour traiter cette
différence de l'agriculture européenne à
travers des objectifs des critères
communs pour que ce salaire équitable
non seulement pour l'agriculteur mais
pour que ça soit clair aussi pour les
contribuables pourquoi il faut ce
soutien à l'agriculture
et quel retour en arrière donc quel est
le retour que l'agriculture donne à la
société lançait de cet angle qu'on va
traiter cette question de répartition
des aides en renonçant à des références
historiques qui ne sont plus justifiable
maintenant en 2010 encore moins en 2013
maintien de découplage ça existe déjà
pour une certaine proportion pour
certains types de productions un
couplage partiel
là je vois aussi une tendance de
certains états membres qui disent que il
faut renoncer à tout couplage qui
peuvent créer des inégalités
en ce qui concerne la concurrence sur le
marché européen
il faut voir il faudra voir de quelle
manière on traite cette question en tout
cas je suis bien conscient que pour
certains territoires
le maintien de l'agriculture n'a pas
seulement un intérêt économique mais
aussi un intérêt territoriale sociale et
c'est une question qu'il faudra traiter
y compris quand on réfléchit à ces
mécanismes pour les règles de des
concurrents pour la régulation publique
et les outils je vous ai dit comment je
vois les choses
mais pour lui les fait partie aussi de
cette approche je disais que pour le
lait j'envisage de venir proposer un
paquet législatif d'ici la fin de
l'année avant la réforme de la pac 2013
une fois que le groupe à haut niveau qui
travaillent actuellement au tour de la
commission présentera ses conclusions
juin sur la base des conclusions de ce
travail je viendrai avec des
propositions et je vais étudier aussi de
quelle manière les règles de concurrence
peuvent s'appliquer pour que le marché
puisse vraiment fonctionner dans le
secteur laitier et pour qu'il ya une
équilibre de rapports de force dans les
négociations entre les producteurs
laitiers est le partenaire dans cette
question va être traitée dans ce que ça
veut dire que vous envisagez de réviser
un peu le droit de la concurrence sur
l'aspect des problématiques purement
agricole il faut voir si l'actuel droit
la concurrence doit être révisée au doit
tout simplement être appliquée de
manière spécifique pour la pour
l'agriculture c'est une question qui est
traités par le groupe tant au niveau des
experts de la direction générale de
concurrence de la commission participent
à ces travaux et vont nous présenter
l'état des lieux
compte tenu de la doua la concurrence a
actuellement qui apparemment peut
présenter cette marge de manoeuvre dans
certains
limite qui n'affecte pas certains types
de contractualisation de négociation qui
s'efforcent est un niveau qui n'affecte
pas le fonctionnement de marchés
communautaires
c'est là peut-être que ça peut se faire
en tout cas c'est une question
j'ai déjà eu une première discussion
avec mon collègue joaquín almunia
j'en aurais pour trouver la bonne
solution la l'ongle dans laquelle je
présente le problème c'est que je ne
demande pas de ne pas appliquer les
normes de concurrence dans le secteur
agricole mais je demande que l'on puisse
faire en sorte que l'application des
règles de concurrence contribuer à un
bon rapport de force entre et entre ceux
qui négocient en fait sur les marchés
donc sais c'est pas qu'on veut pas la
confiance mais on veut que la
concurrence joue son rôle
mais quand contenant un éléphant qui
négocie avec une souris je sais pas
quels rapports des fox de quelle manière
de la concurrence équilibrer les choses
bon après sur les petites structures
agricoles les zones de montagne les
zones difficiles oui ce sont des
questions qui font partie de mes
préoccupations non pas parce que j'ai un
dada personnel sur ça mais parce que je
considère que la diversité agricole dans
l'union européenne c'est une richesse et
que cette richesse doit être maintenus
d'autant plus qu'elles apportent des
choses à la société là où cette
diversité existe et se manifeste et on a
beaucoup des régions dans l'union
européenne où la petite agriculture peut
être compétitive si on définit la
compétitive compétitivité comme la
capacité d'une entreprise agricole de
dégager de leurs revenus qui lui permet
de vivre sur les territoires respectifs
alors quand même une petite exploitation
si elles vendent une production à haute
valeur ajoutée ciel vent d'une
production sur les marchés locaux sur
les circuits courts et donc si les
exploitants arrive à vivre de leur est
venue alors que c'est une exploitation
compétitive elle a le droit d'exister et
d'apporter sa contribution économique
social à son territoire tout aussi comme
une grosse exploitation et donc c'est à
travers cet angle de vue que
je m'intéresse aussi à offrir dans la
future pac des instruments qui permet
aux régions aux états membres qu'ils
essaient de mettre en valeur aussi ce
type d'agriculture et si on est à cette
approche à un territoire
c'est de la même manière pour la
montagne pour d'autres zones spécifiques
dans l'union européenne
je pense que l'agriculture joue un rôle
économique mais joue aussi un rôle
territoriale environnementales sociales
et ces éléments créent de l'emploi et
maintient l'emploi et ce sont des
régions où son agriculture je ne sais
pas quelle autre activité économique
pourrait créer de l'emploi
donc on va essayer de faire en sorte que
dans les mesures proposées dans le
premier pilier peut être aussi dans le
2e pilier de proposer des instruments
qui permet à prendre comme cette
spécificité
merci monsieur le commissaire vous êtes
encore 11 a souhaité poser une question
et il reste 60
il reste vingt minutes à peine donc une
première série de six
si vous pouviez être assez ramassé dans
vos questions marcel deneux merci bon
mois pour faire court monsieur le
commissaire moi tout ce que vous avez
dit me convient
mon inquiétude vient du rock que vous
allez avoir à jouer et comment vous
pourrez résister aux pressions que nous
avons connue sur la politique agricole
commune
moi je suis l'un des pères du un peu et
dit qu'eric commune sans trop me vanter
il faudrait revenir quand même aux
fondamentaux et au traité de rome
on avait donné à roye à cette politique
agricole commune
ce rock continue à avoir besoin
d'exister et et toutes les déformations
qui sont venus depuis vienne de la
pensée unique des économistes par
rapport aux agricultures pour des
problèmes qu'ils n'étaient pas les notes
me des coupelles c'est une construction
c d e
ça vient des pays anglo saxons c'est pas
l'europe alors bien sûr on nous l'a
imposé vous allez avoir vous
à vous reposer la question qu'est ce
qu'on fait pour l'agriculture taille que
vous nous avez défini ce que vous nous
avez défini n'est pas compatible avec
les règles des grands économistes
mondiaux
alors est ce que vous serez capable de
résister ou pas j'espère que oui mais je
voudrais vous dire que votre talent va
est immense parce que toutes les forces
économiques sont contraires ont des
raisonnements que vous développez et que
je soutiens
alors je veux pas insister les ventes
elles mais je veux vous dire qu'il
faudra revenir aux fondamentaux
remettent en cause grecque de omc qui
sont pas compatibles voir par exemple
pour prendre un exemple que les accords
de brera aux ne sont pas compatibles
avec la politique de bioshock onéreux si
je peux me permettre
oui on passe à la question suivante
parce que exactement mais ce que je veux
vous dire c'est que vous trouverez en
france des courants pour vous soutenir à
condition sortir des sentiers battus des
dix dernières années
merci monsieur navarro monsieur le
commissaire et je tenais à vous
remercier et votre présence viennent du
fait je crois que le traité de lisbonne
a ramené bon nombre de pouvoirs nouveau
parlement européen et aux parlements
nationaux jeune fille très heureux comme
quoi même ce traité apporter des choses
intéressantes
vous avez vous avez répondu à goal
nombre de questions que je me posais de
façon positive
et comme le dit maciel de lui en suis
très heureux mais la question que je
voudrais vous poser cap a été posée à
réflexion est ce que vous pensez que le
budget de l'union est conséquent pour
porter la politique agricole qui nous
serait utile de mon point de vue il
faudrait qu'à un moment donné on se pose
la question des moyens parce que
l'europe politique que nous souhaitons
au niveau de l'ambition tente agricole
que dans d'autres domaines nous voulons
porter faudra bien qu'un jour n'ait le
courage au parlement de doubler au delà
merci mon cher collègue monsieur
courteau oui monsieur le commissaire je
voudrais dans le prolongement de la
question lui a été posée par gérard
césar vous direz vous rappeler que le 25
mars dernier les eurodéputés ont voté le
rapport du député escota sur la
politique de qualité ce qui montre que
le parlement européen est favorable au
maintien d'outils de régulation pour la
production de la qualité or justement
vous avez répondu à la question d'un
chirac c'est à moi je voudrais vous dire
que on ne peut garantir l'origine et la
qualité
si on libéralise les droits de
plantation donc j'insiste encore une
fois là dessus c'est un dossier qui va
falloir reprendre mon deuxième point sur
la viticulture toujours je souhaiterais
savoir ce que vous pensez d'une révision
de la politique promotionnelle en faveur
du vin et je considère qu'il serait
utile dans le contexte de crise viticole
que koné y compris l'union européenne
que des programmes soient mises en place
afin de promouvoir nos vins au sein de
l'union européenne
actuellement les crédits dédiés à la
promotion servent uniquement des actions
axées sur les pays tiers
or l'essentiel du développement de la
consommation se fait à l'europe donc
quelle est votre position au commissaire
merci monsieur bourque un thon rouge
ça y est ça fonctionne c'est le
président c'est le commissaire tout
d'abord je jouerai jour m me faire
l'interprète de toutes celles et ceux
qui dans l'agriculture connaissent une
situation dramatique aujourd'hui faut
savoir qu'il ya une non seulement une
grande manifestation hier mais dans tous
les territoires agricoles
aujourd'hui il y à une situation qui est
extrêmement grave et tout à l'heure vous
avez eu concernant les régulations les
ouvertures du marché des mots très
intéressant il faudra qu'ils soient
suivis d'actes précis et faire en sorte
que entre une économie totalement
ouverte et le président à leur a parlé
d'économie offertes et une économie
administrée
il y à un juste milieu qui s'appelle une
économie régulée
chaque fois que l'on nous il faut mettre
des régulations et les régulations là
c'est ce qui m'inquiète un peu mais vous
devriez préciser votre propos à ce sujet
la régulation ne peut pas venir
seulement en temps de crise elle doit
être là à tout moment pour justement
faire en sorte de faire de la prévention
par rapport aux crises et faire en sorte
surtout que toutes celles et ceux qui
ont beaucoup investi qui sont
compétitifs notamment les producteurs de
l'aide et bien d'autres qui ont joué le
jeu vraiment d'une agriculture moderne
et des revenus décents
ce n'est pas le cas aujourd'hui merci
gérard saez gérard le cam pardon merci
seul commissaire la question était
abordée tout ça leur en partie en tout
cas monsieur le ministre de
l'agriculture française nous a laissé
entendre qu'il souhaitait voir évoluer
les règles de concurrence européennes
parce qu'il s'agit de la clé dans le
texte de loi de modernisation agricole
pour pouvoir régler la question
essentielle de répartition équitable des
marges
chaque fois que nous avons des
propositions concrètes à faire dans les
textes on our toque au regard de la des
règles de concurrence européennes
notamment par rapport à des questions de
prix plancher de prix minimum indicatif
ou d'interdiction de ventes à perte
donc nous pensons qu'il est
indispensable que cela évolue si nous
voulons pas que le producteur c'est à
dire l'agriculteur français restent
constamment la variable d'ajustement
autre point très rapide la fin des
quotas ne risque-t-elle pas d'être une
catastrophe environnementale dans des
secteurs qui seraient abandonnées ou mis
au profit de cultures beaucoup plus
polluant merci gérard bailly oui merci
mais c'est chez le commissaire déjà de
vos propos je crois que d'autres
collègues ont dit et combien
l'agriculture était en crise je crois
que le figaro métayère 400 suicides donc
plus d'un par jour actuellement
lundi matin j'avais le comptable à la
maison je peux vous dire qu'ils ne
donnaient les comptabilités des
exploitations il y en a beaucoup c'est
moins 30000 à 40000 euros avec 0 de
revenus donc tout cela qu'il ya une
situation d'urgence qu'il faut prendre
en considération
donc ma question si elle devient pour
loire insisté sur ce sujet là mais une
question très précise en dise quand on
voit l'article de presse par exemple
kennedy la france peut-elle continuer à
limiter seule sa production pendant la
production laitière
c'est pour moi alors la france je crois
à la plus blanc que blanc je vous donne
un exemple
par exemple l'exploitation que je
connais bien puisque c'est celle de mes
fils ont dépassé leurs quotas à partir
du 21 mars c'est à dire dix jours le 12
avril il recevait déjà la facture à
payer est déjà sur la paye de lait
d'hier il y avait déjà les retenues est
ce que tous les pays de l'europe font la
même chose
une telle rigidité pour l'application
des quotas laitiers parce que je crois
que la france ne peut pas toujours être
la seule à votre affaire plus blanc que
blanc
benoît huré jeu commissaire une question
brève
peut-on envisager demain dans le cadre
de la pac une flexibilité ou plutôt une
variabilité des aides européennes qui
tienne compte et qu'ils soient
complètement adapté aux conjonctures
économiques notamment des cours ce qui
permettrait et aux consommateurs et aux
contribuables d'avoir une plus grande
compréhension de la nécessité d'avoir de
l'argent public pour soutenir ce secteur
agricole
oui monsieur le commissaire j'ai entendu
votre exposé introductif dans lequel
vous avez souligné les nouvelles
attentes de la population en terme
d'emploi de respect de l'environnement
et
des défis du changement climatique alors
deux questions très précises dans les
outils que vous allez mettre en place
l'évolution de l'agriculture depuis un
certain nombre d'années est liée aux
politiques agricoles qui ont finalement
incité à une agriculture spécialisé à
outrance fortes consommatrices d'un
temps d'intrants et mécanisée plus
précisément qui a substitué le capital
au travail alors quels outils allez vous
mettre en place pour favoriser des
systèmes d'exploitation plus intégrée et
plus autonomes ma deuxième question elle
sera très courte une seule mon cher
collègue parce qu'il nous en reste
encore 5 et ya plus que cinq minutes si
je puis me permettre
jean bouyer su briller team commissaire
européen et de l'europe
mais question seront très courte vous
avez évoqué que la diversité européenne
étaient des atouts ne pensez-vous pas
quand même qui que ce soit aussi des
handicaps pour la france par exemple
puisque nous avons des disparités
sociales
deuxièmement à handicap les règles
européennes semblent beaucoup plus
rigide que les règles certaines règles
mondiales
et puis là la troisième chose pensez
vous qu'il faille attendre ce sera très
court très court la troisième jaune de
commissaire pensez vous qu'il faille
attendre très longtemps pour mettre en
place les mesures vous préconisez daniel
raoul vraiment il nous en reste encore
quelques-uns il faut laisser le temps
comme celle de répondre je viens écouter
monsieur le commissaire le début de
votre discours et en particulier
l'évolution de la réduction de 20 % des
gaz à effet de serre déjà acquis acquise
plutôt les réductions
la question que je me pose en tous les
cas pour moi vu de l'extérieur qui s'est
un peu un candide par rapport à
l'agriculture c'est la nouvelle tensions
géopolitiques qui va se produire avec la
démographie de la planète est autrement
dit quelle place vous allez donner à
l'alimentation par rapport à la
concurrence sur les biocarburants et les
énergies très bien su botrel et monsieur
le commissaire
la production agricole et
agroalimentaire et soumise à des
pressions très fortes en termes
d'exigences environnementales de
bien-être animal de qualité sanitaire
des produits
or les producteurs voir les industriels
parfois sont interrogatif sur les
respect de ses critères par des produits
entrant en union dans sur le territoire
de l'union européenne en provenance du
marché mondial pensez vous que l'équité
soit respectée en la matière et quelles
mesures seraient envisageables
merci pierre bernard reymond et ensuite
notre collègue pointereau monsieur le
commissaire avez vous déjà arrêté une
stratégie personnelle à l'égard de l'om
c'est oui mes amis buteur français donc
sont venus exprimer leur détresse ir à
paris après l'éleveur laitier c'était
des céréaliers toutes les filières sont
en crise monsieur le commissaire
européen
avez vous la volonté de redonner à
l'agriculture européenne une vraie
dynamique en termes de production
reposant sur les exportations en termes
de régulation sur les marchés
une politique volontariste où les
agriculteurs vivent de leur métier avec
des prix rémunérateurs alors que dans le
même temps les etats unis se
positionnent comme ceux voulant être le
grenier du monde comme jamais il y a des
soutiens et des aides directes à
l'agriculture par exploitation des prix
garantis et des paiements contra
cyclique en fonction des prix le marché
est un soutien à la consommation
voilà je voudrais savoir quelle est
votre position par rapport à cela
merci sur le commissaire
vous imaginez bien que j'aurais du mal à
répondre de manière peut-être très
convaincante à 2 à des questions
certaines questions qui sont très
profondes
ce que je vais vous dire comme ça je
répondre à plusieurs questions en ce qui
concerne mon attitude mes idées mes
propositions qu'est ce que j'envisage de
faire je suis très conscient que je sais
pas comment ça s'est passé dont le passé
mais je suis très conscient maintenant
que c'est pas le commissaire à
l'agriculture qui va sauver à lui tout
seul
l'agriculture européenne déjà je vous ai
dit j'ai pas déjà avec ce constat quand
j'ai pris ma fonction de manière très
modeste et humble je me rends compte que
mon rôle sera plus de donner une
cohérence et faire une médiation des
différentes idées propositions qui
viendront des états membres à travers le
conseil et qui viendra des différents
groupes politiques à travers le
parlement européen donc il ya deux
instances qui vont décider de visages de
la pac
le conseil et le parlement soyons bien
entendu la commission ne fait que avant
l'initiative proposée importer ces
négociations et ensuite ça serait que
ceux qui sont décidés s'applique la
commission applique le plus souvent les
règlements du conseil maintenant vont
être des règlements du conseil et du
parlement
donc mon objectif c'est de faire une
proposition qui intègre de manière le
plus clair possible puis synthétique
possible des différentes attentes des
français des polonais des danois des
espagnols des britanniques ainsi de
suite
ils font partie de l'union européenne et
il vote là bas non mais je sais bien
mais moi j'essaye de jouer mon rôle des
européens
je suis pas là en tant que romain où en
tant que
je ne sais pas quelle nationalité je
suis là en tant qu'européens et si la
pac aurait une crédibilité dans l'avenir
cette crédibilité dépendra de la manière
dont on arrivera à lui donner une
cohérence qui prend en compte les
attentes des différents européenne
peut-être pas de tous les vingt sept
mais il faut que chacun des vingt sept
se retrouve dans ce qu'on va proposer
donc en allant vite maintenant sur cette
question comment résister à des
pressions sur la future pac je vous ai
donné ma réponse
j'essaye d'expliquer ma vision sur la
pac pour essayer d'attirer des idées qui
vont dans le sens d'un soutien de la pac
et non pas défendre la pac parce que je
pense que la pac n'a pas besoin d'être
défendus mais elle a besoin d'être
exprimées d'extrait de manière la plus
claire possible que j'espère que je vais
trouver le soutien et que je vais être
sur la même longueur d'onde avec le plus
possible de membres du parlement avec le
plus possible de d'états membres et à
partir d'une situation réelle actuelle
on est en 2010 on pense à une pac dans
la perspective de 2013
la situation est différente de il ya dix
ans au 15 ans 20 ans 30 ans et il faut
prendre en compte 7
cette réalité mon le budget les moyens
je vous ai répondu aussi à cette
question je vais essayer de venir avec
des propositions qui tiennent compte des
attentes que je vois qui existe déjà
dans les états membres au parlement
parmi les agriculteurs avec l'espoir que
après le conseil et le parlement aura la
sagesse des doter la politique agricole
commune avec le niveau de budget en
rapport avec les ambitions qu'on a par
rapport à cette politique et c'est pour
ça je parle pas mais non du budget parce
qu'il faut pas mettre la charrue devant
les boeufs
il faut d'abord voir qu'est ce qu'on
veut faire avec ce budget qu'est ce
qu'on propose pour la politique de
qualité est là la viticulture
bon la régulation des quantités des prix
pour la viticulture
je disais la décision a été prise non je
n'ai pas répondu à cette question
la décision a été prise deux éliminés
les droits de plantation mais enfin je
le dis si pour certains types de vins
pour certains types de région vous avez
fait référence à la politique de qualité
des outils de régulation peuvent jouer
un rôle
on verra on ne discutera mais il faut
aussi se tenir à des décisions qu'on a
qu'on a déjà prises et puis trouver des
instruments qui peuvent être appliqués
qui peuvent être efficaces maintenant
politique promotionnelle pour le vin
pour les autres produits en général pour
le produit de qualité moi je crois pas
beaucoup
moi je crois beaucoup dans la politique
de qualité je pense que c'était un atout
de l'union européenne sur le marché
international dans les négociations à
l'om c'est aux dons les accords
bilatéraux
c'est un des éléments essentiels pour
moi faire reconnaître les indications
géographiques
et toute la politique de qualité
européennes elle à défendre dans l'e
commerce international et pour répondre
aussi à cette question la stratégie par
rapport à ça c'est que la politique
agricole commune
elle fait pour l'agriculture européenne
il faut pas que la politique agricole
commune européenne nuit à la politique
agricole d'autres régions du monde mais
je vais pas négocier la politique
agricole commune pour des intérêts de
commerce international il faut cependant
que dans les négociations
internationales qui sont pas des marais
seulement pour le secteur agricole qui
sont portées au niveau communautaire
tous les secteurs économiques confondus
l'agriculture il faut qu'elles se
retrouv il faut qu'on trouve un
équilibre dans
dans ces accords on ne peut pas se
mettre en travers et de dire on négocie
pas l'agriculture parce qu'on n'est pas
crédible tout simplement
mais il faut qu'on trouve le moyen pour
mettre en valeur là on a des atouts et
permettre à ceux qui le veulent peuvent
exporter de pouvoir respecter puisque on
est quand même le premier exportateur de
produits agroalimentaires du monde donc
ça veut dire que beaucoup de secteurs
agro alimentaires européennes dépendent
aussi de ses exportations mais il faut
qu'on puisse faire notre politique sur
la base des objectifs qui sont donnés
par les citoyens européens c'est ça ma
ça mes principes
actuellement et dans le même contexte
les normes que nous on s'est imposée au
niveau européen c'est nous qu'on les a
imposées ce n'est pas l'extérieur qu'on
nous a imposé ce sont les états membres
qui ont décidé c'est le parlement qui a
qui a décidé moi je suis bien d'accord
qu'il faut voir de quelle manière dont
convaincre maintenant nos partenaires
sur le plan international d'accepter ces
règles aux faire en sorte que nos
agriculteurs ne sont pas affectés mais
je vous rappelle que les aides directes
sans justifiant font partie aussi parce
qu'on a ses règles que les autres
n'appliquent pas les règles de
concurrence je répondu situation de
crise actuelle je le dis tout à l'heure
dans la rencontre
c'est le président du sénat je suis bien
conscient qu'il ya aussi une situation
difficile du secteur agricole mais qui
n'affecte pas seulement les secteurs
agricole et je dis pas ça pour dire
qu'il faut pas intervenir spécifiquement
pour le secteur agricole mais j'ai dit
que il faut voir ça aussi dans un
contexte plus large
je suis prêt à mobiliser les moyens
qu'on a actuellement à disposition mais
je pense que la meilleure réponse qu'on
peut donner aussi à ces situations de
crise et de détresse dans un secteur
agricole c'est surtout clarté par
rapport à l'avenir ça veut pas dire
qu'il faut pas prendre en compte ce qui
se passe maintenant s'il ya une marge de
manoeuvre à la commission s'il ya une
marge de manoeuvre aux états membres
il faut voir où est le meilleur
niveau pour qu'on puisse intervenir mais
je pense qu'il est important aussi le
signal qu'on donne concernant l'avenir
mon après l'ex ibilité de variabilité
dans les z en fonction des cours en
fonction de prix ça ça veut dire ça
voudrait dire une flexibilité au niveau
budgétaire
et je vous pose une question avec
laquelle je voudrais aussi la réponse
combien d'états membres et est ce qu'on
aurait une majorité au parlement qui
accepteraient une un budget variable
pour la politique agricole commune dans
une situation économique que vous
connaissez bien et où les états membres
se pose des questions par rapport au
budget européen par rapport au
financement de nouvelles politiques
communautaires
je sais que on a des fois on a souvent
des instruments qui peuvent être
parfaite mais malheureusement peut-être
qu'on peut pas les appliquer de manière
parfaite parce qu'il faut qu'on tienne
compte de plusieurs éléments
donc faut aussi qu'on propose des
instruments de la bac qui sont crédibles
qui sont acceptables par par l'extérieur
du secteur agricole sur la diversité
dans l'union européenne
moi je les dis je sais pas si c'est un
handicap je pense que justement avec les
instruments qu'on peut proposer on
essaye d complète cet handicap pour
qu'on puisse maintenir sa diversité
parce que moi je vois pas comment on
peut niveler les systèmes de production
agricole les types de production dans
une europe qui est diverse par par
définition alimentation bio carburant ma
connaissance il n'y a pas actuellement
au sein de la politique agricole commune
des instruments qui stimule qui provoque
la production de biocarburants là c'est
un choix des agriculteurs en fonction de
ce qu'ils peuvent vendre de ce que le
marché lors de leur demande dans cette
condition ça peut être content dans
d'autres non mais on ne stimule pas de
manière artificielle
en tout cas le traité de lisbonne dit
bien que l'agriculture doit assurer la
sécurité alimentaire ne dit pas pour
l'instant que dans l'agriculture doit
assurer la sécurité énergétique
ça veut pas dire que l'agriculture ne
peut pas contribuer à la production de
l'énergie verte
de l'énergie renouvelable mais il n'ya
pas que de cadre aux biocarburants sur
ça voilà je pense que j'ai donné la
réponse que j'ai pu je m'excuse si j'ai
pas pu rentrer dans tout les détails
mais quand je voulais dit l'avenir de la
pac ne tient pas que d'une personne est
heureusement bien mais merci monsieur le
commissaire jean bizet m'avait demandé
de conclure moi je tire une conclusion
très rapide
déjà vous avez des propos très
rassurants sur les perspectives de la
nouvelle politique agricole commune mais
aussi sur les points conjoncturelle que
connaissent nos agriculteurs que vous
avez des réponses qui ne vont pas tout
régler du jour au lendemain mais je
crois que nous sommes très sensibles à
vos propositions vous retire
monsieur le commissaire que au niveau du
sénat puisque vous êtes reçus ici en
france par la première assemblée puisque
on va nous sommes un peu à l'avant garde
de nos collègues députés vous dire
combien nous sommes sensibles au fait
que vous soyez venu devant le sénat et
qu'avec jean bizet nous allons mettre en
place un groupe de travail pour essayer
de vous apporter des éléments sur la
future politique agricole commune
en plus je vous le disais tout à l'heure
nous sommes dans l'examen de la loi de
modernisation agricole qui va venir
devant le sénat le 18 mai et cet après
midi dans cette même salle nous allons
10 y aune et bruno le maire nous aurons
un débat sur la loi de modernisation
mais bien sûr sur l'agriculture en
général
alors merci monsieur le commissaire or
pour que vous puissiez revenir au sénat
je vais vous offrir à la demande du
président du sénat et en accord avec mon
collègue jean bizet mais à l'ensemble
des sénatrices et sénateurs puisque
c'est la première fois que vous
découvrez le sénat vous allez pouvoir
vous plonger bien sûr dans les photos du
sénat mais alors pour la lecture j'ai
bien compris que vous n'auriez pas
difficulté
c'est la fin de cette audition pour la
revoir notre site internet
publicsenat.fr merci de votre fidélité à
très bientôt sur notre antenne